und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend das Europaparlament verleiht
dem ukrainischen Volk den diesjährigen
Sacharow-Preis dafür wie die Ukraine ihr
Leben und ihre Freiheit verteidigen das
mussten sie auch heute wieder große
Teile des Landes waren wieder Ziel von
massivem Raketenbeschuss allerdings
scheint es der ukrainischen Flugabwehr
diesmal ganz gut gelungen zu sein
zumindest die Hauptstadt Kiew zu
schützen nach ukrainischen Angaben
spielen bei der Luftverteidigung des
Landes auch von Deutschland gelieferte
Systeme eine wichtige Rolle der Wahl hat
Putin heute das Kriegsrecht verhängt
ausgerechnet über die von ihm in der
Ukraine annektierten Gebiete in denen
seine Armee aber immer mehr die
Kontrolle verliert Christian Kirsch
berichtet
sie packen Ihre Sachen zu Hunderten ob
freiwillig oder gedrängt Bewohner der
Stadt herson auf dem Weg zum Ufer des
nipro auf Schiffen sollen sie
fortgebracht werden denn der Stadt
drohen Kämpfe die von Russland
eingesetzten Bürokraten fordern auf zur
Flucht
es ist notwendig diese Gebiete zu
verlassen damit die Militärs ruhig
arbeiten und nicht daran denken dass
Zivilisten hinter ihrem Rücken stehen
damit die Militärs ihre Arbeit effizient
und mit wenigen Verlusten für die
Zivilbevölkerung erledigen können
Russland in der Defensive den für seine
Brutalität in Syrien berüchtigten
general solovicin hatte Putin zum
Oberbefehlshaber ernannt zum Kommandeur
der recht erfolglosen russischen Truppen
in der Ukraine und solo Wiki erstaunte
alle mit einem Interview das offen
umging mit der Schwäche der russischen
Armee
schwierige Entscheidungen so der
Kommandeur stünden an vor allem an der
brüchigen Front im Süden
die russischen Truppen dort westlich ist
nibro sind schon seit Wochen in einer
prekären Lage denn ihre Nachschubwege
über zwei Flussübergänge stehen unter
Beschuss und sind schwer beschädigt
deshalb jetzt der wohl anstehende
Rückzug der russischen Armee über den
Fluss in Richtung Osten anschließend
dürften die ukrainischen Truppen massiv
nachrücken Richtung nipro und herson
derart in die Enge gedrängt eskalierte
Putin heute einmal mehr verhängte das
Kriegsrecht über die annektierten
Gebiete noch mehr Rechte für die
Russland hörige Verwaltung und das
Militär
bis zu 60.000 Menschen so die
Ankündigung Russlands wolle man aus
Hassan über den Fluss bringen ehe der
Krieg zurückkehrt in die besetzte Stadt
schalten wir noch zu unserer
Korrespondentin für beganen Moskau für
bin den annektierten Gebieten das
Kriegsrecht zu verhängen was bezweckt
Vladimir Putin damit
also zum einen hat er damit den
rechtlichen Rahmen geschaffen für etwas
das eigentlich seit Monaten in den von
Russland annektierten Gebieten ja schon
Realität ist also zum Beispiel die
Beschlagnahmung von Eigentum oder aber
auch die Zwangs Evakuierung jetzt ist es
auch möglich dass Menschen verpflichtet
werden sich an der sogenannten
Verteidigung der annektierten Gebiete zu
beteiligen das würde dann bedeuten dass
Ukrainer gezwungen werden würden gegen
die ukraineische Armee zu kämpfen und
Wladimir Putin hat in dem Dekret heute
noch etwas anderes verfügt nämlich dass
weite Teile Russlands in
Alarmbereitschaft gesetzt werden sollen
das wiederum heißt dass in Moskau aber
eben auch in anderen Regionen des Landes
ab Mitternacht Ausgangssperren und auch
Reisebeschränkungen zum Beispiel
verhängt werden können
Dankeschön nach Moskau
und dann blicken wir nach Großbritannien
das gerade wieder politisch sehr
turbulente Zeiten erlebt in den sozialen
Medien gibt es unter den Briten derzeit
schon den Running Gag zu sagen ach da
war ich noch mal kurz weg und mir eine
Tasse Tee zu holen und schon ist wieder
etwas passiert
Schlag auf schlagrollenköpfe im Kabinett
kaum ein Tag vergeht ohne neue
Aufregungen mittendrin eine
Premierministerin der die meisten ein
baldiges Ende ihrer erst so kurzen
Amtszeit Voraussagen Andreas
stammberichtet
mein Haus an der Küste alles was ich
noch habe Niklas Wilson 65 am Strand in
Hastings mit Minirente und staatlichen
Zuschüssen kommt er gerade so über die
Runden wie viele Briten hat er keine
langfristige Zinsbindung dank Trust
erklärt er sei die Monatsrate für seinen
Hauskredit um umgerechnet 200 Euro in
die Höhe geschossen
das kann ich mir nicht mehr leisten und
die Zinsen steigen weiter so wie ich
müssen Millionen umschulden sie zahlen
dann sechs sieben Prozent für ihren
Hauskredit das ist ein
Desasters er wird den Blick übers Meer
vermissen in gerade mal sechs Wochen im
Amt hat Liz Trust Millionen Briten wie
Niklas gegen sich aufgebracht so
niedrige Beliebtheitswerte hatte noch
kein premier mitten in einer
Wirtschaftskrise wollte sie auf Pump
Steuern senken statt es erhofften
wachstumswunders erlebte Trust ihr
blaues Wunder ein Erdbeben an den
Finanzmärkten explodierende Kreditzinsen
Renten Fonds die Altersversorgung vieler
Briten mussten vor dem Kollaps bewahrt
werden das Vertrauen den Wirtschafts-
und Finanzstandort schwer beschädigt
die Menschen haben Angst vor der Zukunft
sorgen sich um die Lebenshaltungskosten
die Kreditzinsen die Nöte sind enorm und
lässt Trust scheint überhaupt keine Idee
zu haben was sie dagegen tun könnte dass
sie bis zur nächsten Wahl 2024 oder 25
weitermachen könnte ist ein lächerlicher
Gedanke
um erstmal an der Macht festhalten zu
können und die Märkte zu beruhigen
musste Trust ihren Finanzminister
vertagen Opfern und mit ihm auch ihr
komplettes politisches Programm wie der
Oppositionsführer ihr am Mittag
genüsslich vorführt
ihre
fantasiewirtschaftspläne sind ein
Desaster nun wird alles zurückgenommen
ob Spitzensteuersatz senken
Unternehmenssteuern runter oder feste
Energiepreise für zwei Jahre alles
fallen gelassen Weg warum ist sie dann
noch da
ich bin eine Kämpferin ich gebe nicht
auf ein Kampf wohl auf verlorenem Posten
große Teile ihrer Fraktion wollen sie
loswerden auf dem Weg zur kürzesten
Regentschaft in der britischen
Geschichte und einer verdammt teuren für
Land Leute und ihre Partei
und in den Nachrichten geht es jetzt
erst noch mal mit dem Krieg gegen die
Ukraine weiter Heinz ja die
EU-Kommission sieht mittlerweile
genügend Beweise dafür dass die von
Russland eingesetzten Drohnen aus Iran
kommen deshalb sollen nun Sanktionen
gegen Iran beschlossen werden konkret
gegen diejenigen die für den Bau und die
Lieferung der Drohnen verantwortlich
sind teheran bestreitet Russland mit
Drohnen beliefert zu haben
das Bundeskabinett hat einem
Gesetzentwurf zum befristeten
Weiterbetrieb der drei verbliebenen
Atomkraftwerke zugestimmt nun müssen
noch Bundestag und Bundesrat grünes
Licht geben das Kabinett brachte damit
eine Verlängerung der Laufzeiten bis
Mitte April auf den Weg so wie es
Bundeskanzler Scholz am Montag Kraft
seiner Richtlinienkompetenz vorgegeben
hatte nach einem heftigen Streit in der
Koalition
und die Bundesregierung arbeitet an der
Umsetzung einer
strompreisbremse wie es heute aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium hieß demnach
könnte ähnlich wie bei der
gaspreisbremse ein vergünstigtes
basiskontingent zur Verfügung gestellt
werden für den übrigen Verbrauch viele
der normale Strompreis an finanziert
werden soll diese Entlastung durch das
abschöpfen von zufallsgewinnen
das Ladenetz für Elektroautos soll
deutlich ausgebaut werden
Verkehrsminister Wissing hat dazu ein
Maßnahmenpaket vorgestellt so soll es
bis 2030 eine Million öffentliche
Lademöglichkeiten geben bisher sind es
knapp 70.000 den neuen Plan hat das
Kabinett heute beschlossen
fußball-Bundesligist Schalke hat Trainer
Frank Kramer von seinen Aufgaben
entbunden schalke hatte gestern im
DFB-Pokal bei Hoffenheim 1:5 verloren
und steht in der Bundesliga auf dem
vorletzten Tabellenplatz ein Nachfolger
wurde noch nicht bekannt gegeben
die Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 1 15 23 36
40 49 und die Superzahl 2 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdft.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
die Wetteraussichten morgen im Nordosten
sonnig sonst zunehmend bewölkt und von
Westen her Regen
örtlich Gewitter 12 Grad in Vorpommern
bis 22 Grad am Alpenrand am Freitag bei
13 bis 21 Grad sehr unbeständig mit
kräftigen Schauern und einzelnen
Gewittern am Wochenende wieder häufiger
Sonne und bis zu 23 Grad warm
das Wasser schon von uns mit unserem
kurzen halbzeitjournal um 0.45 gibt es
dann unser heute schnell Update mit
nazan- auf Wiedersehen bis morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]